okay wir rufen dann wenn er ausgestiegen
ist herzlich willkommen im sellicon
Valley und dann jubeln wir ganz lange
bis einer sagt Stopp
[Applaus]
herzlich willkommen im sellicon valent
wir sind bereit für Party
[Gelächter]
oh mein Gott
[Applaus]
was machen wir heute backen wir
irgendwas wir backen wir machen Party
wir machen einen Musical ich habe
geschminkt nicht Weihnachten hallo
[Gelächter]
bis später
[Musik]
kommst vom Keller hoch
[Gelächter]
er kommt aus dem Keller
wir brauchen Fahrstuhl also manchmal die
Jasmin steht dann hier
ich entschuldige mich jetzt schon mal
fürs ganze Video
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute haben wir wieder eine ganz
besondere folge ich muss sagen ich bin
ein bisschen ich habe nicht ganz so gut
geschlafen nicht weil ich angst oder
irgendwas habe sondern weil ich mich
einfach sehr freue auf meinen heutigen
Gast ich bin ziemlich aufgeregt weil es
für mich halt auch einfach ein Mensch
ist der eine Frohnatur ist ein
Sonnenschein ein Star den ich schon seit
meiner Kindheit wirklich kenne und
verehre ich bin mit ihm aufgewachsen
sozusagen er sieht immer noch genauso
jung aus wie damals er ist
er ist Schlagerstar Schauspieler
Moderator er hat ein wahnsinnig gutes
Herz ist sozial engagiert und ich freue
mich so sehr dass er heute aus meinem
Keller zu uns kommt hier ist Ross Antony
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
also
gesehen
[Gelächter]
hallo meine Lieben schön dass Ihr alle
da seid also ich muss ja echt sagen
ich habe es mir sehr gut vorgestellt
aber nicht so gut und was ist da
wirklich eine Allroundtalent er kann
singen er kann tanzen er kann moderieren
er kann Schauspielern er ist
Dschungelkönig er kann einfach so alles
und jetzt kann auch noch backen schon
lange
backen bis schon lange backt begeistert
wir lachen einfach den ganzen Tag ich
glaube immer wenn ihr jetzt schlechte
Laune habt schaut euch einfach dieses
Video
anschauen
was drin macht
dann wollte nur raus
alle Menschen sind dabei fertig gewesen
also wir machen was ganz besonderes
heute oder ja schön dass du bei mir bist
wirklich danke danke danke für die
Einladung weil ähm ich hätte nie gedacht
dass das passieren wird
zu erreichen ist wirklich schwierig
vielleicht zur Vorgeschichte es war so
Bürgermeister Waghäusel ruft mich an der
Thomas und ich dachte es geht um
Grundstück und Bauplatz um irgendwas was
du falsch gemacht haben ich dachte er
ruft mich deswegen an und sagte einfach
Ross Antony möchte Dich gerne
kennenlernen und dich besuchen und ich
dachte mir okay warum ruft mich jetzt
der Bürgermeister Waghäusel deswegen an
jedenfalls haben wir dann rausbekommen
dass du einen Freund hast der unseren
Bürgermeister und der Freunde
wir haben uns dann kurz danach auch
kennengelernt und es war so lustig weil
anscheinend die E-Mails bei uns nie
angekommen sind weil ich bin schon ein
Mensch der immer zurückschreibt aber die
irgendwo waren Fehler im Leben
jedenfalls ist eine lustige Geschichte
der oben und der Bürgermeister haben uns
zusammengebracht und jetzt bin ich froh
dass sie da ja schön und wir backen was
ganz tolles zusammen machen
neues Backen mit Ross und es hat viele
Rezepte von meiner Oma drin die ich
weder machen wollten ganz tolle
Geschichten drin mit deiner Oma mit
deiner Mama wirklich richtig toll und
ich muss sagen ich bin ja die Rezepte
durchgegangen und habe sogar was könnten
wir backen was könnten wir backen und
sie sind sehr Englisch angehaucht weil
in England auch geboren bist wunderschön
ein Wunsch von meine Fans und die haben
gesagt es wäre schön wenn wir die
englische Rezepte auch bei uns zu Hause
backen könnte und du hast was ausgesucht
ja weil ich dachte wenn wir jetzt hier
gemeinsam stehen machen wir vielleicht
nicht eine Torte sondern wir machen
diese Cupcakes das finde ich eine tolle
Idee Cupcakes leicht lecker und einfach
ja darf ich das Rezept dann für meine
Community auch du darfst natürlich
morgen ist alles drin alles wir haben
dann alle Rezepte einfach ausprobiert
wir machen einfach die eigene Kategorie
Ross aber ein Geschenk für Weihnachten
ich finde es sind auch nicht zu viele
Rezepte nicht zu wenige genau perfekt
ausgesucht
einfache Rezepte
[Gelächter]
nehmen wir das jetzt hallo
treffen sich zwei Nachbarn die eine sagt
zu der andere hey Silvia es wäre schön
wenn du abends mit deinem Mann so
rumknutscht auf dem Sofa dass du
wenigstens den Vorhang zu machen
könntest du sagte dass Susanna es wäre
schön wenn du die Brille aufsetzen
würdest dann wirst du sehen dass es dein
Mann ist
[Musik]
so wir fangen mit dem Zutaten an das
hast du schon erwähnt sein genau
gerichtet ich sag gleich was zu einer
Zutat dazu ja denn diese Zutat ist
speziell die kannte ich auch nicht
vielleicht kannst Du was dazu erklären
für die Muffins verwenden wir 100 Gramm
weiche Butter 200 g Zucker eine Prise
Salz etwas Vanilleextrakt 3 Eier die
sind bereits auf Raumtemperatur 200 g
Mehl plus Backpulver oder ihr nehmen das
backmehl
140g Minz etwas Muskatnuss und
Lebkuchengewürz
und das ist die Frage minsmed so sieht's
aus ne genau aber in Deinem Rezept Buch
hast du auch ein Rezept dafür auf 15
nämlich
du kannst vielleicht erklären ich kannte
es tatsächlich gar nicht also es ist
tatsächlich kein Fleisch ne genau das
ist was anderes was willst du das sagen
das ist das eine Mischung aus ja also
ich habe gelesen auch Fleisch verwendet
hat das ist eigentlich wie so ein
ähnlich wie so ein Chutney irgendwie ne
oder das ist super oder genau aber ein
bisschen anders man kann es mit Brandy
zubereiten schreibst du auch ohne
Orangensaft alkoholfrei Gewürze sind mit
dabei und aber alle Info steht dann
genau
meine Stimme die bleibt heute einfach
weg von lauter Lachen ja das sind die
Basis Zutaten und eigentlich sind ja
Cupcakes recht easy eigentlich das hast
du gesagt eigentlich
dass das Dekorieren ist eben immer das
Schöne und so wir fangen an okay ich
reicht immer alles rüber und du kannst
jetzt alles rein machen weil das kannst
du gerne machen ja schön so wir fangen
mit den mit den Butter an es muss
schäumig gestorben werden
wir direkt Zucker und Vanille dazu
genau ich präsentiere das immer sehr
schön
[Gelächter]
frische Flasche
da ist oben dann immer so viel
Vanillemark
e
erstmal Stopp perfekt aus perfekt ja
dann machen wir natürlich den die Eier
dazu
[Musik]
immer schön einrühren das ist verbindet
und dann das nächste guck mal was für
eine schöne Konsistenz ist jetzt schon
hat ne ja genau beim Ei muss man immer
aufpassen dass es schön homogen wird
über einrühren lassen und dann das
nächste
hier gibt's aber sogar ein Programm für
sponge cake dann macht man alle Zutaten
rein und dann ist es auch All in One
cake wow
dann rührt er erst langsam dann kurz
schnell und dann ist auch alles homogen
weil hier vorne kann man natürlich die
ganze Zeit abrufen lassen ach so
verstehe
das sieht wirklich schön aus und jetzt
können wir alles andere anders
erst die Haare im Rachen jetzt das Mehl
im Rachen
dieses kennen ja viel auf der ganzen
Welt aber hier in Deutschland war das
nie bekannt aber das ist super ne gab
dafür braucht man kein Backpulver genau
das habe ich dann quasi als backmehl
genau
ach schön komme wir räumen ein kleines
bisschen auf während wir
ich habe den Deckel vergessen
[Gelächter]
man sollte auch die Rosinen sehen können
Rosinen oder eine andere ja definitiv
zu Hause haben sollte als Engländer
dieses minesmee wir haben das
tatsächlich wirklich
Weihnachten es schmeckt es schmeckt
natürlich sehr weihnachtlich aber man
kann das überall verwenden und es gibt
diesen extra wie sagt man dass diesen
extra Schuss irgendwas ne das ist schon
wichtig und ist man das mit süßen
Gerichten oder isst man das zum Beispiel
auch zum Fleisch oder Gemüse genau
okay guck mal ich habe da schon eine
Muffinform gerichtet wenn du willst
kannst du die präsentieren jetzt gerne
auch gerne präsentieren
oder gerne schon mal einfüllen
wir sollten einfach dein Buch hier noch
hinstellen also was ist ganz toll finde
es ist
in meiner Küche
[Gelächter]
so das ist das liebe ich muss sagen wenn
ich deine Videos anschauen ich liebe es
wenn du Sachen befühlst kannst du mir
das Zeigen das ist so geil wie du das
machst ich mag es halt immer wenn man
mit Haare
ich mag es halt immer wenn alles sauber
abläuft
also warum bin ich nicht selber drauf
gekommen ne ich ich
oh mein Gott
dann hat man nämlich immer die gleiche
Menge ich habe ja auch meine Community
vielleicht ich habe meiner Community
gesagt dass du kommst und alle haben
sich sehr gefreut also wirklich war
durchweg positives Feedback dass du bei
mir bist nimm einige Fragen auch von
euch gesammelt die würde ich dir dann
einfach immer so zwischendurch mal
stellen ja zwei Sachen auf einmal machen
kann
möchte zum Beispiel jemand wissen was
deine absolute lieblingszutat ist beim
Backen also meine absolute
lieblingszutat ist definitiv Streusel ja
also ich liebe das ich liebe wie bei dir
ich liebe dass du dekorieren das ist mir
super wichtig dekorativ
und was ich ganz toll finde ist auch
Zimt ja Zimt macht alles auch also ich
könnte Weihnachten dein ganzes Jahr
celebrieren ne aber es macht alles
wirklich toll sehr genau
Lieblingsrezept von mir was du mal
nachgemacht hast oder sagst das Rezept
das ist hammer also es gibt mehrere ne
ich fand diese Comic Torte was du
gemacht hast ganz toll weil du hast
innen von innen gezeigt wie das alles
ausgesehen hat fantastisch Minion ist
natürlich super in meine Familie
angekommen und ich habe wirklich genau
[Gelächter]
ja und was ich schön finde ist wenn du
minimuffins machst ja das sind so lecker
und dann die du die befüllst du die mit
irgendwas ne also mit Schokolade oder
was auch immer und du hast wirklich und
das weiß ich ganz toll an dir finde du
du kriegst neue Sachen wo ich denke halt
mein Gott warum habe ich das auch nicht
ausgedacht ne dass man das so machen
kann du machst es wirklich nicht ganz
verstehen warum die Leute Dich so lieben
also wirklich ein bisschen toll Mensch
ist wirklich ein toller Mensch so
bodenständig und nett und lieb und
höflich und Wahnsinn
lieber auf den ersten Blick muss ich
sagen
so schön richtig toll mein Team hat auch
ich muss dich jetzt schon mal vorwarnen
mein Team hat Spiele vorbereitet
challenges und spiele denn zu Gast bei
Sally ist immer so ein Format damit ich
natürlich meinen Gast besser
kennenlernen wir wollen sie wollen uns
beide immer herausfordern also mein Team
ich weiß auch nichts davon
ihr wisst aber es gibt eine Abmahnung
wenn es was schmuddeliges ist
und ich möchte auch was vom Gast lernen
das heißt Du darfst mir später auch was
beibringen
es wäre angebracht
genau das würde ich gerne lernen
[Musik]
okay was war so als Kind deine Musik
Inspiration meine Musik Inspiration
damals war Kylie Minogue kannst du
nochmal Banane Rahmen
natürlich
ganz toll ja ich bin ein kleines
bisschen älter als du musst auch aber
nur ein bisschen zwei Jahre 29
[Gelächter]
sieht gut aus ne ich habe so die
Angewohnheit ich muss immer alles
auskratzen
ja also ablecken tue ich nicht weil ich
nicht naschen will beim weißt du auch
warum ich du darfst ablenken das macht
mir gar nichts mehr macht das überhaupt
gar nichts wenn jemand was ableckt aber
wenn ich so viele naschen würde ich auch
Baby nee dann könnte ich das nicht mehr
essen was ich backe also verstehe kein
Problem
[Musik]
gerade ne es ist schon anders so tolle
Oma bitte einfach in den Backofen für 20
25 Minuten
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das kann ja heiter werden Gott ja dann
würde ich sagen können wir doch die
Backzeit überbrücken mit einem Spiel
oder
ich weiß es
nicht so
[Musik]
herzlich Willkommen zu Gast bei Sally
wir haben für euch ganz ganz tolle
Spiele vorbereitet und unser erstes
Spiel ist riechen
als erstes mal beide einmal die Brillen
aufsetzen bzw
und ihr dürft dann erraten was das ist
aber das ist alles hat alles mit Essen
zu tun es ist nicht so genau
ich bin so geruchsempfindlich ich bin
auch ich kann nicht riechen du kannst
nicht lustig ich
kann nicht versprechen
und wir beginnen mit dem Spiel jetzt
schon
hätte doch einfach sagen können macht
die Augen zu für was brauche ich so eine
Taucherbrille ich gebe dir als erstes
Mal
ich gebe dir
es sieht aber aus
ich gebe dir einmal die Kaffeebohnen in
die Hand dann kannst du deinen Geruch
neutralisieren
vom Lidl das richtig
gibt es dafür auch einen Punkt
wir sehen uns alle
ich gebe dir jetzt den ersten Behälter
bzw ich halten die
hin
[Gelächter]
ich kenne den Geräusch das Ding
ich weiß nicht wie lange Du noch
aushalten wird
[Applaus]
zweiter Geruch
[Gelächter]
mein Lipgloss riecht
nicht
drauf
warte warte warte ich muss mit
Vanille auch in meinem Leben
so es geht weiter
[Applaus]
zwischen Gewürz aus meinem Garten
irgendwie Kräuter kein Gewürz ist ein
Kräuter
Kraut so kommen wir zum nächsten
spät nur Schnaufen
bist du schon da
die Bio Mülltonne
of the nice
also deine Antwort
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
Musik ausgesucht
wie Kakaopulver
Schokolade dann nehme ich Kakao hallo
Mama nee ich kann nicht im Moment
[Applaus]
so das letzte
kannst du es erraten
[Applaus]
aber nicht wie Rose
eine seifenblume dann lassen wir es
dabei
hey super darf ich das jetzt abziehen
[Gelächter]
meine Damen und Herren DJ
fangen wir an let's go hier ich bin vor
dir
ich habe keine Ahnung ich weiß ja nicht
es ist er warum machst du das die ganze
Zeit
ein bisschen stärker wird
also ich würde sagen Pfeffer okay
[Gelächter]
Apfelmus
servierte bitte
alles gut jetzt ich habe ich werde nicht
ein Einzel richtig
so Nummer 3
also
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ich gebe dir noch 5 Sekunden hallo warte
mal ähm
vier
drei zwei
eins okay
wie heißt es die
Amerikaner
okay
oh oh
das ist schrecklich
[Gelächter]
was könnte sein Tintenfisch
okay dann lassen wir es mal tippen
Reinigungsmittel
du hast noch vorhin im Video gesagt
gehabt
lebkuchengeback lebkuchengeburt
gewürztiv
Schokolade
geschmolzene Schokolade
deine Finale Antwort lautet
Schokolade also Nutella oder so
[Gelächter]
was ist
[Musik]
super
das war's und wann sagt ihr uns ob was
richtig was falsch war so ich zeige euch
jetzt
nach vorne genau
Nummer eins
Pfeffer haben wir richtig ja
jetzt weiß ich ist meine Handcreme
aber wie geil und die kann man essen
hast du daran direkt
kann man wirklich
geil
das war ein bisschen schwierig ne
ach hier
habt ihr einen Würfel
Thymian
da wart ihr beide leider falsch aber
ganz ehrlich ich finde Oregano Thymian
ich finde er hat einen Punkt verdient
weil ich kann auch vegano und Thymian
absolut nicht auseinanderhalten Zone
ähnliche Gruppe ich finde das schon
okay ich nehme das gerne super danke
und die Biomülltonnen hast
[Musik]
und dein Lieblingsgewürz oh ja das hatte
ich im Gesicht
nimmt das erste Video ich habe so rein
gerochen und dann habe ich reingeht
so und dann einmal noch hier Kakao
Schokolade das war Kakao aber es ist
Schokolade ja und wenn man die Sachen
nicht sieht die man riecht dann finde
ich schon eklig manchmal komisch
du hast backschrank gesagt du hast
gesagt er hat Katzenfutter
ich finde wenn man
das nicht sieht dann
manche Gerüche nicht so toll
und das zusammen hat aber der Kaffee ist
sehr stark dennoch habe
beide richtig genau
bei dem ersten Moment schon stark riecht
und dann
machen wir später wir sammeln alle
Punkte und ganz zum Schluss gehalten
ja natürlich
gibt es eine Pokal
wir sagen noch nicht wow
jetzt geht's weiter
[Applaus]
und Papa ist da hey alles gut
Mehmet schön dass du da bist
mein Lieber
ich freue mich
toll großer Star hier
großer Stein Waghäusel jeder kennt den
Präsident
hier Präsident
alles kann ja mein Papa
[Gelächter]
Meerschweinchen bei uns nicht gesehen
und das und das im muslimischen Haushalt
meiner Freunde
der Papa hat der erinnert sich jetzt
nicht dran aber wir haben damals
tatsächlich zusammen Dschungelcamp
geguckt als du auch dabei war aber das
ist schon
der Papa liebt einfach wirklich
mein Leben schon gesehen krass äh also
wenn ich jetzt angefragt werden würde
ich würde nicht mitmachen können weil
ich so wahnsinnig so wahnsinnig Angst
und Ekel vor kleinen Tieren habe also
ich muss sagen damals schon viel anders
ne es war eine von die ersten Staffel wo
ich dabei waren und äh ich habe das
immer in England angeguckt äh die das
Vergleich und ich fand das immer so toll
ich wollte das unbedingt machen und ich
hatte damals nicht zu verlieren ne und
dann habe ich wirklich gesagt ich will
nicht unbedingt das ist so eine tolle
Show und ich bin so stolz drauf wenn ich
dabei sein könnte dann habe ich das
gemacht habe ich nie im Leben
mitgerechnet dass ich gewinnen würde und
dann habe ich der wirklich was meines
Lebens gehabt und das war wirklich ganz
toll ich habe das musstest du dich
irgendwie anfangen so wahnsinnig
überwinden
oder man kann sich nicht vorbereiten
dafür ne ich hatte auch Angst vor
Spinnen vor Ratten für alles mögliche
eine natürlich damit war ich blöd weil
ich das alle erzählt habe ne und dann
wurde ich immer wieder gewählt für jede
Prüfung musste ich alles durchziehen
aber ich habe das Gefühl weil wir hatten
keinen Kontakt zu den Außenwelt ich habe
keinen Computer kein Handy kein gar
nichts ich bin aus dem Dschungel ein
viel besserer Mensch geworden ne und ich
habe genau und ich hatte so viel mehr
gelernt ne und ich bin viel ruhiger
geworden ob das kaum zu glauben
innerlich ne obwohl ich immer eine
riesen Freude fürs Leben haben weil ich
liebe ich glaube das merkst du ne ich
bin niemand der das Leben angreift und
genießt das ist super wichtig und wenn
ich damit die Leute zum Lachen bringen
kann dann tue ich das auch gerne ich
meine ich muss auch sagen ich habe
damals Popstars mit verfolgt ich war ein
wahnsinniger No Angels Fan ich war noch
ein wahnsinniger Browser
if the somebody Baby Song
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
einfach schön wenn man nur meine Stimme
hört nicht mein Gesicht dazu sieht man
wird denken dass ich immer noch 19 20
bin weißt sowieso
vielleicht kannst du mir ja gleich ein
bisschen Gesangsunterricht geben auf
jeden Fall ja bei mir ist schon immer
wichtig dass ich auch was lerne von
meinem Gast eko Fresh war da er hat mir
das Rappen beigebracht wir haben ein
Punch Rap gemacht so eine Punchline ähm
ich weiß natürlich nicht mehr was wir
damals gehabt haben was war denn der
Song es war ähm komm doch jemand drauf
wir waren die sind so Giraffe
ich backe leckere Kuchen und Torten
davon ganz viele verschiedene Sorten
jetzt bringe ich noch den Kaiserschmarrn
ins Spiel
aber ist davon bloß nicht zu viel
[Applaus]
jetzt
weiter ne
wir sehen wirklich wunderschön
[Musik]
abgekühlt ist auch immer wichtig und
hier haben wir einfach nur Buttercreme
aus Butter Puderzucker Frischkäse ganz
einfach
nur wenige Tropfen wir gucken einfach
mal was für eine Farbe wäre erreichen
möchte
erzählt und ich habe es auch in deinem
Buch gelesen so dass viele Backen kommt
auch von der Oma ist definitiv ich habe
meine Oma wie du deinen Papa abgöttisch
geliebt ne und wir haben sehr viel Zeit
zusammen verbracht ich war immer bei ihr
zu Hause und zuletzt ist sie dann zu uns
gekommen weil sie hatte Probleme sie
hatten einen huft gebrochen und dann
müsste sie dann zu uns kommen und leben
und trotzdem haben wir weiter gebacken
und sie hat mir sehr viel beigebracht
sehr viel ich habe sie so geliebt sie
hat mir immer so tolle Märchen
vorgelesen und Geschichten erzählt und
sie hat immer an mich geglaubt ne was
war denn dein
Lieblingsrezept was Oma so zubereitet
hat Oma konnte wirklich ein ganz toller
britische Stollen Backen ja was schönste
mit Stollen ist es hat immer viel länger
gehalten ne und wenn man konnte das
wirklich genau Früchtebrot
übrigens wir haben auch ein Früchtebrot
in dass der Backpulver und das ist vegan
es gibt einige vegane Rezepte drin und
wahrscheinlich kann man es auch gut mit
veganen Alternativen auch jedes Rezept
zubereiten
definitiv da ist es
richtig schön mir fehlte das ja also mir
fehlte so ich hatte eine Oma
aber ich hatte ja nicht so diese
typische deutsche Oma deswegen kann ich
diese ganzen deutschen Rezepte gar nicht
von meiner Oma oder Mama sondern hat mir
das immer alles selber beigebracht und
äh von meiner Mama habe ich das Ganze
türkische Backen und Kochen gelernt
weißt du wie meine meine Schulfreunde
früher hatten dass sie gesagt haben so
die Oma die kocht heute für mich das gab
es bei mir nicht
wir machen das ein bisschen somit ja
genau gefällt dir der Grünen Ton oder
sowas bisschen greller machen nee das
ist super gut
und dann habe ich in der Kunden für
viele Leute fragen mich warum hast du
dann ist dein zweiter Backbuch
ausgebracht und es ist halt meine Oma
lebt nicht mehr schon lange nicht mehr
aber ich will trotzdem dass ihre schöne
Rezepte weiterleben das ist mir super
wichtig ich glaube bei dir ist es
tatsächlich so ne dass ich finde schön
dass viele Leute die Backen zu Hause die
Rezepte von meiner Oma nach ist auch
richtig schön also wenn ihr das auch mal
durchblättert hat er hat auch ganz ganz
viele Bilder mit seiner Oma dabei viele
tolle Geschichten mit dabei Bilder aus
deiner Kindheit
schön ausgesehen immer noch schön aus
junger hübscher Mann
immer immer
alle Blicke auf dich das ist Wahnsinn
einfach schön und sehr positiver Mensch
deswegen freue ich mich dass du hier
bist und ich hoffe du kommst immer mal
wieder vorbeikommen ich würde mich sehr
freuen ja wir können wirklich Sachen
Experiment in Sachen experimentieren so
ne so jetzt kommt das schönste Teil
eigentlich ne
nehmen wir unsere Spritzbeutel mal die
Schere ist bei dir ich würde ich einmal
nehmen
keine Schere und Messer aus der Hand da
sagt man immer man würde sich dann
streiten ach so deswegen liegt das immer
auf
also
okay
und wie war das für dich das Kind hast
du also hast du auch sehr viel mit die
mit Mama und Papa in die Küche gestanden
und mit Mama viel Papa war ja viel
arbeiten meine Mama war auch aber die
war dann trotzdem die meiste Zeit da und
mein Papa war immer viel im Garten viel
draußen als hätte wirklich ich sag's
euch gut streng erzogen und du hatte
nicht so wie viele freiheitliche Freunde
aber ich hatte eine wahnsinnig schöne
Kindheit mit meinen Eltern die haben
viel mit uns gemacht wir waren viel in
Freizeitparks wir waren viel im Zoo in
im Luisenpark also wir waren wirklich
wirklich viel unterwegs meine Eltern
sind immer Mühe gegeben dass wir gut
erzogene gebildete Kinder werden
das ist das beste erfinden
überhaupt das ist so toll das ist
wirklich mein Liebling
es ist so geil wo wirklich auch wir
gehen später noch in Shop zu uns und
dann
schaust du einfach was dir alles gefällt
und was du brauchen kannst ja oh Gott
das hättest du mir sagen
okay ich bin gespannt
[Applaus]
ich glaube wir stellen einen
Spritzbeutel kurz in den Kühlschrank die
ist so ein bisschen weiß hier drin so
warm ist
die hatten wir kurz im Kühlschrank und
jetzt können wir eigentlich anfangen die
Tannen Cupcakes ja so dekorieren ne
einfach hoch aufspritzen wie so genau
ich liebe das Geräusch
so ein richtiges asmr oh nein
du hast ein kleiner
ich finde es richtig toll dass du ja bei
mask singer war das war wirklich eine
eine Zeit die ich nie vergessen werde
also das erste Mal als ich die Kostüme
bekommen haben ne ich glaube ich habe
wirklich gedacht ich kriege keine Luft
weil manche Kostüme haben ein riesen
Kopf und da kann man gut aber ich hatte
natürlich einen schmales Kopf ne und
mein Nase hat immer gegen den
wegen dir in den Front dieser diese
diese Mesh dann nehme kannst du dann da
Feier atmen und singen ich meine lustige
Geschichte erzählen ne also ich habe das
erstmal alles angezogen das war immer so
es war ein Body und dann so Wasser ist
alles das was du kam ne und dann haben
die gemerkt die haben keinen Schlitten
gemacht aber ich habe gesagt ich muss
jetzt auf die Toilette und das hat
wirklich bei mir 20 Minuten gedauert ja
und ich habe gesagt du musst wirklich
hier ein Schlitz vorne machen weil kann
nicht immer jedes Mal wenn ich auf die
töchern ich bin sehr oft auf die
Toilette gegangen weil ich immer so
aufgeregt war ich habe das und dann
haben die das wirklich mit klettbund
gemacht das war wirklich toll und die
haben gesagt er aber du musst die ersten
Wochen erst Frau dich bewegen sich
bewegen nur du musst natürlich auf die
Frauentoilette gehen ich war so wirklich
die die Zuschauer hinter die Bühne weil
keine weiß wer unter die Maske steckt ne
wirklich gar nichts außer nur einem
Person und die mich immer begleitet hat
ne und dann ich bin immer auf die Frauen
Toilette gegangen ist war die Gespräche
von den Frauen war sehr lustig ne das
war so oh Gott wie kriege ich das hin
und ich dürfte natürlich nicht lachen
weil ich habe so ein hässliches
männliche Sachen und dann ja und dann
habe ich mich ich musste
die ganze Zeit na gut und dann
irgendwann
genau die drei Wochen natürlich wurde
das gedacht dass ich doch Mann bin und
hat das gehört in meine Stimme und so
und tatsächlich habe ich vergessen dass
ich ist nicht mehr auf die Frauen
Trailer zu gehen und dann war ich
einkaufen in der Stadt
und ich bin plötzlich also day in die
Frauen Toilette gegangen und da waren so
viele Frauen den ich war so hi
du siehst mich während
der Toilette
es war richtig geil jemals aufgeklärt
warum du auf der Frauentoilette warst ja
ich habe dem schon gesagt dass ich bei
der Masse ich habe es vergessen weil ich
immer es war natürlich dann Routine ne
dass ich immer auf die Frauen aber Gott
sei Dank ich habe mich immerhin gesessen
[Gelächter]
aber duftet ihr quasi entscheiden was
ihr für ein was du für ein Kostüm hast
also oder wird es dann für dich
entschieden weil eigentlich darf man und
Sommer ja nicht erkennen wer du bist nee
aber das schönste ist das Team vor Ort
die haben eine natürlich geguckt was für
ein promiziöse den ging und weißt du was
die gemocht haben so und die wussten
schon dass ich Flamingo sehr mochte und
deswegen haben wir natürlich dann einen
Flamingo
gesucht damals sind übrigens der
roststreusel die sind so schön richtig
schöne weihnachtsmischung
hübsch damals war man Alpaka dabei da
haben auch viele mitgeraten ob ich es
bin weil ich Anpacker so liebe also ich
habe auch tatsächlich auch gedacht ja ob
du das warst ja und beim Brokkoli
dachten uns einige aber ist
wahrscheinlich weil ich halt immer
Brokkoli und Sellerie esse
sehr sicher dass du nicht warst weil du
singen kannst danke
das muss jemand sein der nicht aus der
Musikbranche kommt aber trotzdem
verrückt genug ist hiermit zu machen ist
es Sally hahaha
ich bin mir schrieben dann aber echt
Zuschauer mit dem geschrieben das bist
nicht du du kannst wirklich besser sehen
ich kann es nicht besser aber danke
was ist denn beim Singen das wichtige
sagst du jeder kann singen lernen oder
denkst du es ist schon ich meine ich
glaube es ist schon ein Stück weit sehr
sehr viel Talent dabei denn es gibt ja
stimmen die sind einfach außerordentlich
gut und es gibt Stimmen wo man sagt okay
beim Frauenchor reicht's sie kann singen
aber es wird jetzt kein Superstar aber
würdest du sagen jeder Mensch kann es
lernen also so eine Technik ich finde
ich finde tatsächlich dass jeder Mensch
ganz wirklich lernen nicht jeder kann so
gut singen aber ich glaube tatsächlich
dass jeder ein Ton halten kann und das
ist natürlich von Koh sehr wichtig wenn
man ein Solo Künstler oder Künstlerin
sein möchte dann muss natürlich jemand
das was Besonderes haben ne und es gibt
natürlich Menschen die glaube ich die
sind mit damit angeboren ne dass die so
gut singen kann ne aber ich habe deine
Stimme auch gehört und ich finde du hast
wirklich eine schöne Stimme und mein
Mann der der Opernsänger ist auch gesagt
Lehrer der könnte dich viel beibringen
definitiver Körperhaltung oder siehst du
du kennst dich schon gut aus
Körperhaltung auf jeden Fall weil viele
Leute werden die singen die gehen in
sich ein und das ist natürlich die
mussten viel Luft hier unten einsammeln
können ne und mit Atmen ist ein Technik
ne da muss es auch gut können ne ich
habe es immer noch schwer damit manchmal
aber nicht so längere Sätze singen muss
ich bin immer kurz davor ich bin so ja
ich finde immer so im Auto oder in der
Dusche so mitbringen lauthals da geht
einem einfach zuerst die Puste immer
auch man steht dann da lernt man Dinge
hier okay ich sag jetzt einfach mal wir
wir im Unternehmen lieben alle Karaoke
ich sag jetzt einfach wir und alle haben
unterschrieben das ist auch Leben ähm
und da ist schon so dann singt man da so
laut als mit und die geht einfach
irgendwann diese Puste aus aber es ist
immer lustig ich merke das auch wenn ich
wenn ich mich wenn ich aufgeregt bin
oder ich in meine Stimme nicht aufwärme
nach einer halben Stunde ist meine
Stimme auch dann fertig ne dann habe ich
immer Probleme und ich merke das hat das
hätte ich doch schon viel besser
aufwärmen müssen so man muss konsequent
sein man muss wirklich sich hinsetzen
die halbe Stunde die Stimme Aufwärmen
wirklich viele Übungen machen und auch
viel viel den halt schön ne das ist
nicht
oder schon wie man sagt ich war damals
im Schulchor weil ich in eine Musik
tatsächlich eine relativ schlechte
theorie-noten
weil die nur gesungen hast und sonst
nicht
getraut aber ich hatte eine recht
schlechte Theorie Note weil ich einfach
Musiktheorie nicht so es war nicht so
meins es hat mich nicht so interessiert
wann Beethoven geboren gestorben und das
muss und dann wusste ich aber ich kann
die
Note 4 mit einer mündlichen eins
korrigieren wenn ich in den schulkor
gehe und dann war ich im Schulchor aber
meistens habe ich gesungen wirklich aber
dann habe ich die eins gekriegt
sieht das nicht schön aus guckt mal das
perfekte Gebäck für euren
weihnachtssonntag für ein Adventssonntag
das ist doch einfach schön es ist
wirklich schön wenn man man kann als
Familie das machen die in die Küche
nehmen man muss nicht alleine da stehen
es gibt genug zu tun für alle ne und man
hat wirklich Spaß und das ist eine Zeit
wo man wirklich als Familie
zusammenleben kann und dass dieses Leben
genießen kann und nicht richtig besseres
und die sind für Kinder sehr einfach
ganz zu machen ja also meine Kinder
würden das auch leben die würden hier
sofort mit dekorieren sind leider beide
noch in der Schule sonst hätten als ich
eigentlich darf ich gar nicht sagen dass
du da warst aber vielleicht schaffen sie
dann gleich noch nach der Schule das
dass sie dich noch treffen aber wie wäre
es wenn wir die gleich einpacken mit
nach Mannheim in unserem Shop nehmen
statt dann verkosten lassen oder einfach
neues Geschenk rausgehen mit dazugeben
oder
schön und ich weiß dass mein Team jetzt
noch im Spiel vorbereitet hat
ich hoffe es hat nichts mehr mit dem
Geruchssinn zu tun aber ich freue mich
aufs nächste Spiel
kommen wir zum zweiten Spiel jetzt
spielen wir kartoffelauf
gefreut euch ein bisschen zu früh ich
erkläre euch mal die Regeln ihr werdet
hier in diesem Parcours einmal
entlanglaufen
ich mache es mal kurz vor ich stelle
euch eine Frage sobald ich die Frage
gestellt habe müsst ihr auf mein GO
warten dann dürfte laufen
und einmal hier drüber hüpfen und
Wasser und dann dürft ihr die Antwort
singen oder einfach beantworten am
besten ja antworten nein okay
der andere natürlich auch noch mal raten
okay und das waren ziemlich schlauer
Bauer denn der hat keine Kartoffeln ja
wir haben natürlich auch ein bisschen
also da ist unsere
okay
kommen wir zur ersten Frage ja welches
der fünf Spice Girls fehlt hier
scary Spies
Ginger Spice Spotify
3 2 1 go
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
das ist der Grund warum das meins ist
so kommen wir zur zweiten Frage bzw
Aufgabe wie tanzt man zu Macarena 3
Stopp Stopp Stopp
drei zwei eins go
aber
[Applaus]
gleichzeitig
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wo ist mein Kartoffel
stehen die Wasser wieder richtig
Kartoffel ja
genau
kommen wir zur dritten Frage was hatte
Olli P 1998 im Bau drei zwei eins go
[Musik]
h
Flugzeuge boah
richtig geil
du brauchst meine Liebe nicht gib mir
mein Herz zurück bevor es
auseinanderbricht
umso leichter so leichter wird also wir
haben beide einen Punkt
die Kartoffel fallen lassen ich habe es
gesehen
so komm jetzt zur nächsten Frage an
welchen Wochentag kann die da von den
Fantastischen Vier nicht
an welchen Wochentag kann die da von den
Fantastischen Vier nicht drei zwei eins
go
ich glaube beide wissen es nicht
[Applaus]
ist es die da sie da am Eingang steht
oder die da die mir den Kopf verdreht
ist es die da oder die da irgendwas mit
Freitag richtig
[Applaus]
ja das war unser vierte Frage schon
kommen wir zur Frage Nummer 5 welcher
90er Song beginnt so every night in my
dreams I see you I feel you 3 2 1 go
[Applaus]
[Musik]
schwierig wenn man das nur wenn man nur
den Text hört oh Siri geh lieber aus dem
Weg mein Schatz geh lieber aus dem Weg
Katze der rosster Frage was fragte sich
Haddaway 1993 drei was zwei zwei was
fragte sie
was fragte sich Halloween 1983
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
die letzte Frage was
mit deinem
Handy Games
zur letzten Frage
was für ein Spiel wollten die Backstreet
Boys 1996 beenden
3 2 1 go
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Pause machen uns fresh und fahren nach
Mannheim ich würde sagen wir machen
einfach ein Karaoke auf fahren nach
Mannheim in Shop packen die Cupcakes ein
das letzte Spiel spielen wir auch dort
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt geht's los oh mein Gott
also was ist ganz toll finde ist dass du
dass ihr denkt über den Natur auch und
das ist euch super wichtig ne mit den
Gewürze was was bei euch wechseln so und
hat hat Murat auch gesagt viele Leute
vergessen die Bienen leben durchs Winter
auch weiter ne und ihr habt das so
ermöglicht natürlich bei euch ist das
auch wirklich dann Pflanzen gibt die
jährlich dann immer und ähm genau
und ich merke das jetzt schon aber du
bist so trotzdem ein sehr dankbarer
Person für alles was Du hast es ist
nicht selbstverständlich
Lehrerin geblieben werden
aber trotzdem wenn ich ganz toll ist es
als wir dieses Tor jetzt gerade gemacht
haben ne also Murat hat auch gesagt wir
geben jede Mensch eine Chance und das
bedeutet ihr habt natürlich die
Möglichkeit
Menschen mit Behinderung auch anzunehmen
definitiv das ist so wichtig keine
Ahnung Menschen auch wirklich mit
einzubeziehen zu involvieren egal woher
sie kommen egal ob sie gesundheitliche
Einschränkungen haben es ist einfach
wichtig dass man alle Menschen
unterstützen fördert ja
das finde ich toll das finde ich ganz
toll
welchen Song ich kenne entweder mama mia
kann ich auswendig ja oder nein kann ich
auswendig aber music
esskin orlande
[Musik]
so are say thank you for the music for
giving
home
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja schön
habt ihr gut gearbeitet der Film gerade
was geiles richtig geil pass auf Euch
auf schönen Feierabend
[Gelächter]
sehr freuen darüber es ist da jetzt bist
du dran
[Musik]
habt ihr Spaß
richtig geil wir haben heute schon
gebacken
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt gleich im Shop bin ich
mal gespannt das war ein Wechsel auf
einmal
[Gelächter]
wir sind gleich im Shop
komm Spucke aus dem Mund wieder ein
bisschen
Mama die Tür auf schnell und jetzt
geht's los
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wie geil ist das Wetter
ich war öfters in Mannheim
ich finde es wirklich toll ich habe so
geil das Hotel hier übernachtet und ich
war mehrmals Einkaufen ja
du denkst dass ich nicht das erste Mal
bei dir war
aber jetzt könnte ich euch wirklich
meine Vorfreude zeigen
mitnehmen
professionelles Mikrofon dabei
Logo drauf und lebst du gerne hier in
Mannheim
ja doch ich finde unsere Region schön
Rhein-Main-Region ist die beste einfach
beste ja hier sind wir bei den Quadraten
Q6 Q7 und da gehen wir jetzt rein und da
sind wir
wie süß angucken
[Musik]
okay jetzt sind wir hier im Shop und das
Team hat alles vorbereitet jetzt kommt
das letzte Spiel und wird uns
hoffentlich erklären was
[Musik]
wenn es weiterhin so gut für mich läuft
über den France einfach den Laden
[Gelächter]
wir werden jetzt Song erraten das
bedeutet ihr macht Pantomime das
Publikum wird erraten müssen auf
wirklich
Publikum erwähnt okay
und wenn sie es erraten dann
an und ich darf nicht mit warum soll ich
mittragen und
[Applaus]
das war gut
[Gelächter]
richtig gesehen
du darfst okay
sehr gut
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
du weißt es ist nur symbolisch okay
aber
[Applaus]
ganz toll
das ist ganz geil
du darfst
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
was mache ich gerade
[Applaus]
okay aber
[Musik]
okay 3 2 1
[Applaus]
die Gewinner werden noch gekürzt Moment
Moment jetzt kommt erst noch das letzte
Spiel weil das war ja so ein einfaches
Spiel ja jetzt kommt noch unser Chat
Spiel
t
ihr dürft jetzt schätzen wie viele drin
sind
da reingegangen
[Gelächter]
1 2 3 Zeilen 31,32
eins
zwei
ich habe meine Zahl aufgeschrieben
wir reden vom Stück
nein einmal dann würde ich mal sagen was
denkt denn das Publikum ja genau wie
hier das sind da drin
ich kann so ich dachte wenn ich hier so
fünf liegen wenn ich hier fünf fliegen
und dann habe ich gedacht wie viel
kannst du am Rand liegen mir fehlen der
Mitte ab sowieso multipliziert
weißt wie ich meine ich habe so gedacht
wenn das so hoch ist und fünf Stück in
der Reihe lege
und dann noch mal rechnen
ja ich habe jetzt keinen Kopfrechnen
gemacht ich habe Kopf raten gemacht es
müssten mehr sein
350 oder so bestimmt sind so 350 oder so
er hat angepasst da muss ich meins auch
anpassen warte kurz ich rechne ganz kurz
noch 10 Sekunden warum
8 3 7 6 5 4 3 nein nein nein nein
[Gelächter]
einfach die Höhe dann
und den Durchmesser und dann hat man
noch den ich habe
sieben acht Stück
ja aber es sind
a Projekt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
so wir brauchen noch einmal die Ballons
guck dir das mal an noch mal Applaus für
die Jünger
genau und wer möchte darf jetzt gerne
ich glaube wir müssen die Muffins ein
bisschen
schneidenbild
unser Pressesprecher hier
genau Mama bin
[Gelächter]
wir probieren jetzt die Cupcakes
rossfeiert seinen gewinnen und wir
freuen uns dass wir alle hier am Ende
lassen
soll mitnehmen was er möchte er soll
sich hier ausleben er ist einfach der
beste es war ein wunderschöner Tag mit
ihm war richtig richtig schön so also
alle in die Küche
der Tag war fantastisch ich habe so viel
Spaß gehabt aber wirklich als ich ankam
bis jetzt gerade eben es war wirklich
wunderschön sally ist so ein toller
Mensch und ich bin sehr dankbar dass ich
den Tag mit ihr verbringen kann
[Musik]
für Weihnachten
Ecke für angefangene
ich kann nicht glauben ist ich bin
wirklich ein Paradies ist das schönste
Tag meines Lebens und äh ich glaube
jeder der backt wird es verstehen wird
verstehen wie toll das ist hier zu sein
und wenn ihr noch nicht wirklich bei
Sally in ihrer Shop waren dann im muss
wirklich gehen kommen weil es ist eine
Reise wert und es ist so toll es ist
wirklich so toll ich flippe gerade aus
ich glaube ich hätte auf die Toilette
geben müssen weil bei mir ist ein
bisschen schwierig jetzt gerade
aber nee mega und so ein bodenständiger
tolle Frau Wahnsinn
was ist los
[Musik]
hast du alles gefunden ja alle sind noch
viel mehr was für ein wunderschöner Tag
danke dir das war so toll diesen Tag
werde ich nie vergessen
falsche Richtung
[Musik]
so wollen die mich verarschen das haben
wir einfach Ihre Party gefeiert und
alles da gelassen es darf die Murat
wieder den Kärcher nicht
[Musik]